over 300 million years ago before the
age of giant dinosaurs Earth was covered
with giant insects
imagine a world where dragonflies are
the size of crows and millipedes are as
long as cars
welcome to the Carboniferous period
why were insects so enormous during this
time
what did oxygen have to do with it
and why did these insects
this is
and here's what
looked like in the age of giant insects
the Carboniferous period was one of the
most transformational periods in the
history of Earth
the planet's land masses were beginning
to form the supercontinent of Pangea
extensive swamps and warm humid forests
dominated the landscape
and giant insects weren't the only huge
creatures roaming the planet there was
also a vast array of marine life like
early forms of sharks and a giant
amphibian that would reach up to six
feet long
now enough talking let's travel back in
time 300 million years ago and dive into
the Carboniferous age
now the first thing you'd probably
notice would be the giant insect-like
creatures
one of the most iconic was the Mega
neura this insect resembled a modern day
dragonfly except with a major twist it
had a wingspan of up to 75 centimeters
yeah scarier than that though it was
carnivorous
hunting down other insects and small
amphibians
hopefully it doesn't come for you
so that thing is in the sky but on land
you'll have the arthroplura
this millipede-like creature could grow
up to two and a half meters long
luckily it wouldn't go after you it
preferred munching on decomposing
vegetation hey before we talk more about
these giant insects there's another
giant issue we need to worry about and
that's our planet's ecosystems and how
important it is to help them stick
around till the end of this video to
check out an inspiring project from the
folks over at Planet wild another creepy
looking insect was the pulmon of
Scorpius
this was a giant scorpion that mostly
roamed the swampier areas of Earth they
could grow 70 centimeters long
there were also giant cockroaches that
grew to 10 centimeters
and mayflies with 45 centimeter
wingspans
so it's safe to say that you'd have a
lot to watch out for when you're
wandering around in this period but the
question is how did these insects get so
big anyway
well you may have noticed as you've been
hanging around in the Carboniferous age
you feel a lot more energetic and alert
maybe you've had an easier time running
around
this has to do with the oxygen levels in
your current world
research has estimated that the
atmospheric oxygen levels were as high
as 35 percent during this period compare
that to the 21 we breathed today
oxygen was one of the key factors in the
gigantism found in insects at the time
but why would this make them so giant
insects breathe differently from other
creatures insects don't have a
circulatory system to transport oxygen
instead it gets delivered directly to
their tissues through a network of tiny
tubes called the trachea and the more
oxygen in the atmosphere the bigger
these insects are
but there might be more reasons why the
insects grew to this size another theory
suggests that the insects were forced to
grow so large due to oxygen toxicity
yeah as amazing as oxygen is you can
have too much of a good thing too much
oxygen in your body can create what's
known as free radicals these are
unstable molecules that can damage your
cells and even damage your DNA
in the case of our insects they were
forced to grow this big
otherwise they'd suffer oxygen toxicity
growing larger would slow down the rate
of oxygen absorption making it harder to
suffer from too much oxygen
and the same could happen to you the
longer you hang out in this period the
higher oxygen levels will cause you to
experience nausea respiratory issues and
even some effects on your nervous system
now insects were arguably the stars of
this age but they weren't the only
things to experience massive change
during the Carboniferous period
this time was known as the coal age
that's because of the extensive coal
beds that formed after ancient forests
decayed
these coal beds are one of our main
sources of energy we're still using them
today
and a lot of the fruits and veggies you
find in the grocery store may be
descendants of plants from over 300
million years ago the Carboniferous
period saw the evolution of the first
seed bearing plants creating more
diverse ecosystems than we've ever seen
before
wait what's that over there
looks like a dinosaur
oh hey little guy
turns out this wasn't a dino just one of
the first reptiles to ever appear
but if you stick around a couple of
million more years we'll enter the
Mesozoic Era which was known as the age
of dinosaurs
thinking of change the atmosphere was
another part of Earth that evolved
during this period
Earth had a lush greenhouse-like climate
when you first arrived warm and humid
temperatures to support the swampy
forests we've been mucking about but as
the period progressed over millions of
years the climate transitioned to what's
known as an ice house Earth state
the temperature would get significantly
lower and ice sheets would begin to form
mainly in the southern hemisphere
but why did this happen
well as we've been exploring this crazy
period Earth's land masses have been
slowly coming together to form a
supercontinent known as Pangea
and when land masses this big start to
move it can seriously affect ocean
currents wind patterns and Global
Climate now the rainforests have
collapsed which has led to a decline in
the fauna and vegetation that were
previously booming
and with the rainforests in Decline well
that means oxygen levels are being
reduced
know it our massive insect insects are
dying and going extinct
without the higher levels of oxygen
available to support their size well
these giant insects can't survive
the lower oxygen levels and a drier
climate have created a habitat better
suited for smaller insects
also happening at this point early
reptiles are starting to take over
making the landscape way more difficult
for the insects
okay now with Pangea fully formed we've
entered the Permian period
what happens at this point in history
well that sounds like a story for
another
what if
hey don't click off just yet I've got
two more awesome videos from planet wild
an organization restoring Global
ecosystems their videos don't just
highlight issues they show you
actionable ways to help the planet while
transparently documenting how Planet
Wild's missions work and the impact they
have their work is made possible through
monthly subscriptions and that gives
members a direct impact on what planet
wild projects they're helping Finance
I've been a member for a while now and I
love it because I can see exactly where
my money goes and what kind of
difference I'm making and if you want to
make the same kind of impactful consider
subscribing as well and to see what kind
of work Planet wild is doing we'll check
out these two videos in this one they're
bringing back Europe's Wildcat and
saving a baby lynx that was separated
from her mother and got caught in a trap
in this other one they're equipping and
teaching Italian civilians to fight
wildfires check them out